Let's have a drink!
Come on, I said, let's have a drink!
What about the pitch?
Don't worry.
Big soldiers are in town.
Come on, take a look.
Come on.
We stopped in Tokyo.
You should know that better.
This place isn't without restrictions.
No, but those girls are.
Sarge, you act like you don’t know what we’re doing.
My colonel says we’re ambassadors of kindness.
We’re just trying to build friendly relations with our little Japanese friend.
Aren’t we?
I don’t think you heard everything the colonel said.
Let’s go.
My colonel doesn’t like when you interfere in my affairs.
Just mind your own business.
We’re not going to fight.
Right, ambassador?
Okay, you got your joke.
Now get it together and get out of here.
No one tells me what to do.
You better calm down, soldier.
Step away.
Help your friend.
Please, no trouble.
Get them out of here, Nakamura.
Get them out, get them out.
I should pull you out, soldier.
But I think you've had enough.
Shut your column and stop crying.
If I find any of you in this area again,
I'll hand you the book.
Now move.
Did the soldier boys drink too much?
They drank, Nakamura.
And it wasn’t tea like your little girls drink.
Soldier doesn’t understand.
You don’t understand, Nakamura.
White girls with GIs.
But the girls are good girls.
They entertain the GIs.
They talk to them.
They don’t even drink.
Look, we’ve all been through this.
But all the nightclubs in Tokyo
have girls who entertain GIs.
Entertaining is one thing.
White girls are another.
Will Ginza be without restrictions?
I’m just reporting what I see.
I don’t make the rules.
I wait for the day you come back to me.
Then the white bird will sing,
And the bird will fly away.
And it will greet the spring on the mountain,
And it will now shine upon the Message
And she will be loved again
And she will serve again
So be honest
Truly
Because she will serve again
And she will be loved again
And she will serve again
So be honest
Truly
Because she will serve
Actually, she’s one of the most popular actresses in Tokyo
I suppose she’ll land a major role in the States
Maybe
Listen, Bronson, you didn’t come here for a personal interview, did you?
Nakamura asked me to talk to him
You're wasting your time
-5
from home.
-4
Dozo.
-3
Zimbabwe, Sumi.
-2
Hello, Robert.
-1
I'll be through soon.
Ah!
Patani.
Sorry.
I forgot.
I guess I'll never learn.
Do not forget.
You like to tease me.
Don't you like me to tease you?
Well, come on.
If you don't like it, I promise I'll never do it again.
Like sometimes.
Do you like me to kiss you?
Sometimes.
Sometimes?
Most times.
Now?
Now.
You are beautiful.
Sumi, men are not beautiful.
Women are beautiful.
What are men?
Well, they can be handsome or good-looking, but never beautiful.
You are beautiful.
And you can't speak English.
I can't, too.
Pretty hair.
Beautiful face.
Good head.
Smart.
Nice eyes.
Beautiful eyes.
Strong chin.
And you have cute lips.
And you have kissable lips.
Ah, I see.
You really are beautiful, Sumi.
And you are handsome.
Now you got it straight.
That's the way a wife should talk.
I am not your wife yet.
Oh, okay.
Be independent now.
But you wait till I get you back in Illinois.
I'll show you who's boss.
I will be a good wife.
I want to learn all the American ways.
I want you to be proud of me.
I'm proud of you just the way you are.
Better leave now.
I have to get ready for the next show.
You must go.
All right.
I'm going.
Clumsy.
Clumsy?
I mean clumsy.
Yeah, I know what you meant.
I like teas, too.
Well, I'll tell you what I'll do.
I'll get you a big new fan when we get to America.
A big fan?
Sure.
Electric fan.
Baka me.
What's that?
You are crazy.
Now go, please.
How about dinner at the Imperial Gardens on Wednesday?
Okay.
I'll pick you up about 8.30.
Sayonara, Sumi.
Sayonara.
Oyasuminasai.
Odaiji.
Odaiji ni.
That's enough.
Mata ashita.
Goodbye, Robert.
Right.
We'll file a report with the provo, Marshal.
Thank you very much for the information.
Bye-bye.
All right.
How much did you lose?
I had about 80 bucks worth of yen with me when I started.
I think I must have had about, oh, 50 left.
We'll write it up as 50.
She got my wallet with my girl's picture.
That's what hurt, not the dough.
The old man in?
Yeah, that reporter Bronson has him cornered.
What are you doing here?
Somebody stole my wallet.
I should have run you in last night.
All right.
What was her name?
Suzuki?
How'd you know?
Figures.
That's Smith in Japanese.
All right.
Room 106, down the hall.
Look, I'm not sick.
106, soldier.
But, Corporal.
Oh.
Oh, no, Corporal.
You don't understand.
You see, we got...
106.
And come back tomorrow.
106, and come back and sign this report when you're through.
Know anybody named Suzuki, Sarge?
They call this a man's army.
Make sure a copy of that report gets to the kid's outfit.
A little company punishment will do him some good.
Hello, Sarge.
I just stopped by for my weekly press releases.
Incidentally, I talked to the Major about the Ginza.
He told me you hadn't reported it.
Are you going to?
I'll write you a letter, Bronson.
What makes you so miserable, Douglas?
Look, I got a job to do,
and I'm doing it the best way I know how.
Well, you're a good MP, Sergeant,
but you can't clean up Tokyo alone.
This is Japan.
Why don't you relax and enjoy things?
Live a little.
What do you know about Japan, really?
What, you learn in pachinko parlors,
beer joints, and geisha houses?
Morning, Major.
I have three off-limits orders for you to sign, sir.
Anything exceptional?
No, just the usual.
Two for B-girls, one for serving meth with alcohol.
Ginza?
No, that's the one Bronson was talking about.
What's the story on this, Bob?
Habitual. Third offense in the last six months.
Nakamura will open up a new location
as soon as we close him down.
At least we keep him somewhat in line.
How about the monthly activity report?
That'll be ready tonight, sir.
How does it look? Any improvement?
A little, but not much, I'm afraid.
Kids they send over here getting any younger
will need an MP for every GI.
Can't get that bad.
I just hope my next top kick can maintain your record.
Thanks, Major.
Well, be sure that that report
gets to Far East Command headquarters tonight, will you?
I'll take it by myself, sir.
Well, that won't be necessary.
Well, I'm going by headquarters anyway
to shop for a gift in Shinjuku.
Oh, something special?
Well, sort of. It's a gift for Sumi.
Hey, have you kids set a date yet?
Right after festival week.
Oh, fine, fine. Well, best of luck to you.
Thank you, Major.
Hey, Bob.
You could probably use a little time before you leave.
Why don't you take some? We'll get along.
Thanks. Maybe I will.
Good night.
Konbanwa. May I help you?
No, thanks. I think I'd just like to look around for a little while.
Some coverings?
No, no thanks.
Very fine Japanese cigarette lighter.
Only 1,500 yen?
No.
Very beautiful, is not?
Doll is of the imperial family.
Time of the samurai.
Very great Japanese prince, Hideyoshi.
-3
This doll, emperor's daughter.
-2
17th century.
-1
Very beautiful Japanese princess.
With that hairdo and the obi tied in front?
More like the emperor's girlfriend, huh?
Forgive me.
The sergeant is familiar with some of our customs.
I think I'd like to see some fans, please.
Very beautiful Japanese fan.
No, no, that's not what I'm looking for.
Do you have any others?
Perhaps the sergeant would like one of these.
No.
How about the ones in the window?
My very best Japanese fan.
You like?
How much?
4,475 yen.
Too much.
I'll give you 1,000 yen.
Best price.
3,975 yen.
Okay?
Deal.
Wrap it up in a nice package, please.
Thank you.
For a Japanese girl?
For a Japanese girl.
Not Hideyoshi.
Hideyoshi carried one sword.
Two swords, just plain samurai.
Sayonara.
Hey, hey.
What are you doing in there?
Hey, let me go.
Come on out of there.
Come on.
That's the kid.
Somebody get a doctor.
Don't just stand there.
Get an ambulance.
What I can't understand is why you drew your gun in the first place.
It was instinctive, sir.
I didn't think.
Couldn't you see he was just a kid?
When I tried to put the gun back, the other boy jarred my arm.
Headquarters is going to love this.
I'm sorry, sir.
I know it was just an accident.
But the big brass aren't going to understand.
We're in Japan as goodwill ambassadors, not just soldiers.
We can't afford accidents.
I know that, Major.
There's nothing more we can do about it now.
I hope that boy lives.
Prepare a detailed statement of exactly what happened.
We'll get a report to headquarters before they get it from the Tokyo police.
I'll see to it right away, sir.
And don't leave anything out.
The smallest detail may prove to be important.
Right.
One thing more.
Have Williams take your name off the roster.
I don't want you pulling duty for a while.
I'll do that, sir.
Excuse me.
Come in.
Do not eat very much.
I'm not very hungry.
No, no, no.
You must not blame yourself.
The other boy caused the accident.
I can still see that kid lying on the street.
He will recover.
Tokyo Hospital is very good.
Do not worry.
What do you think?
A lousy way to end a wonderful three years in Japan.
I feel bad when you say that.
I'm sorry.
I'm afraid I'm not very good company tonight.
You have so much to be happy for.
So many nice memories and happy times.
You're right.
You only see the brightest side.
No more worries?
No more.
I brought you something.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Aren't you going to open it?
In Japanese, it's bad manners to open presents.
In American, it's bad manners not to open presents.
Do you like it?
It's beautiful, Robert.
Not a tourist band, but a fine Japanese band.
Pine tree means good fortune and eternal happiness.
It does, if I don't break it.
Before proceeding to your questions and answers, gentlemen,
I have a brief statement I'd like to make on behalf of the United States government.
We sincerely regret the unfortunate accident
that resulted in the death of the Japanese boy Yukio Kojima.
What does the Army intend to do?
I've assigned Captain House to investigate the matter.
The Army's course of action will depend on the Captain's final report.
Has Sergeant Douglas been arrested?
No.
According to the information available to us at the moment,
the shooting was an accident.
And what information is that?
We have a signed statement by Sergeant Douglas.
What if the Sergeant's statement is not true?
Mr. Osaka, Sergeant Douglas has been under my command for the past three years.
I have had no occasion whatever to doubt his word.
Major, will Douglas be court-martialed?
That's quite possible, depending again on the findings of the investigating officer.
Major realizes, of course, that the dead boy was a Japanese national?
Yes.
Does the Major know that our countries have treaty commitments
placing matters like this under Japanese jurisdiction?
Yes, I'm aware of that.
The United States-Japan Administrative Agreement
specifically provides for a Japanese jurisdiction in a case like this.
Will you turn Sergeant Douglas over to the Japanese authorities, if requested?
Mr. Osaka, you know very well that's not my decision to make.
However, I presume the United States will honor all of its treaty commitments.
Major, you mean there's a chance the Army will surrender an American soldier
to the jurisdiction of a foreign government?
I'd like to reserve comment on that question, Mr. Bronson,
until after all of the facts are in.
Well, Major, let me put it this way.
Is there a possibility that Douglas will be turned over to the Japanese?
I have to let my last answer stand, Mr. Bronson, if that's all right with you.
Thank you very much, gentlemen. I think that about covers the matter.
-8
Yes, I checked. The Japanese may request that Douglas be turned over to them.
-7
Right. No, the Army hasn't done a thing. You know the position they're in.
-6
No, Douglas isn't in custody yet, but the pressure is building.
-5
When this story breaks, it's going to break big. I'll be in touch with you as soon as I've got
-4
anything definite to report. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Goodbye.
-3
Robert, I came as soon as I could.
-2
I'm sorry to have you come here, Sumi. The boy died this afternoon.
-1
Yes, I heard. I'd like you to take me to his parents' house. I want to talk to him.
This is the address.
You think it is wise for you to go?
I want to say I'm sorry. Maybe I can help in some way.
Well, perhaps.
I'd like them to know that I didn't intend to do it. I want them to understand.
All right. I will take you.
by Sugtan
Have you seen your family before?
No, I'm here to see an American.
Oh, I see.
Did your father pass away?
Mr. Kojima?
I'm sorry for your loss.
Thank you very much.
Mr. Kojima, it's Douglas.
I'm very sorry for what happened
and I want to help.
The Americans are deeply sorry about this trip.
If there’s anything we can do...
What can Americans do?
Our child won't come back.
What are you saying?
Mr. Kojima is very troubled.
At least maybe I can help with some of the expenses.
No, Robert, do not.
Please.
He truly wants to do something to help.
We don’t want American money.
We want our child back.
I was just trying to help.
Robert, we have to go.
What are you saying?
More than your American money, we want our son.
I thought it was the right thing to do.
For Japanese people, it's a traditional sentiment.
What about my money?
I’m trying to get our son back.
He will not accept it.
Because I’m American?
Mr. Kojima is overwhelmed with sorrow.
It would be better if you would leave.
It was an accident.
Can’t you understand their feelings?
They suffered a great loss.
To understand their emotions...
Excuse me.
American murderer!
Filthy American!
Please go away.
You're disrespecting Japan.
Please leave this place.
I'll take him to my father’s house.
Thank you for your help.
First of September.
Tsumisan.
Where’s your mother?
Good morning.
What is it?
The stone is standing.
Bring the medicine.
Tell Mom it's okay.
It’s already alright.
Here you go.
I'm home.
Welcome back.
Good evening.
Tsumichan, you’ve grown.
You’ve gotten better.
That’s nice.
Did I do well?
You’re really kind.
Very smart.
Thank you.
Being too smart is bad, they say.
Don’t you know how to smile?
What’s wrong?
I won’t smile at a murderer like an American.
What are you saying? To our guest?
I don't like her.
Big brother likes to joke.
She’s not my guest.
Enough already.
Her death was an accident.
If someone had taken responsibility, her friend would've been there.
This is not about another man.
What are you saying?
It’s written in the newspaper.
It says she deliberately killed Yukiyo Kojima.
That's not a lie.
She is lying.
It’s not a lie.
Look at this.
I can’t read Japanese, I don’t know what it says.
Find that girl and tell the truth.
Robert, tell them.
Don’t you dislike her?
What’s life like for a Japanese man like him?
And for other Americans?
You can’t believe that, can you, Toshio?
Sumi, do you think I could kill someone cold-bloodedly?
-5
Do you think I could kill anyone in cold blood, a Japanese boy or anyone else?
-4
I do not know what to believe.
-3
If I were Japanese, you'd know what to believe, wouldn't you?
-2
I did not mean it that way.
-1
Neither did the fellow who threw this rock.
That's not fair. You twist my words.
I'm not twisting anything, but you're willing to take this kid's word over mine and make me the liar.
That is not true. You're not giving me time to think.
Well, I'll give you plenty of time to think.
I... I'd better be going.
Robert, please.
Oh, yasuminasai.
Major, I want action on this immediately.
No coddling, no butt-passing. Get it done and get it done at once.
I understand, sir. Captain House's report will be on your desk this afternoon.
That won't be good enough.
It's following procedure according to Army regulations.
Let me worry about the regulations.
Sir, a soldier's career may be at stake.
More than that may be lost if we foul up this case.
Your sergeant's career is not very important in the overall picture.
I don't intend to see him railroaded, but we can't cover up for him either.
By that, you mean Sergeant Douglas may have to stand court-martial.
There's always a chance the Japanese may insist upon his being turned over to them for trial.
I'll start proceedings for a court-martial at once.
Will that be all, sir?
That's all for now.
I'm sure everything in this report is correct.
It happened pretty fast, but I think it's all there.
Because, you know, the other boy says he never touched your arm.
He claims you fired without warning and without provocation.
He's lying, Major.
It shouldn't be too difficult to break a story down in court.
Incidentally, you know, you have the right to choose counsel.
Sir, I've heard rumors that the Japanese may want jurisdiction over me.
To be quite frankly, there is that chance.
I think they'll be satisfied with a court-martial.
If it should come down to my word against the boys, I'd hate to have them decide.
I understand their courts are pretty fair.
That may be so.
But here's one soldier that would be happy with a court-martial.
Well, we'll see.
Is that it, sir?
Except that you understand that now you're restricted to quarters.
Yes, sir.
I'm sorry about this, Bob.
But we'll clear it up just as quickly as we can.
Yes, they decided to let the Japanese try, Douglas.
No, it's not official yet, but I got it from a well-placed source in Far East Command headquarters.
Get your soft sisters out. Play the human interest angle up big.
His mother, his friends, hometown.
Light a bonfire under his congressmen and senators. That'll get the ball rolling.
And keep a line open for me. This is hot.
Right. Bye-bye.
Come on in.
How'd you get up here?
An off-the-record visit. I told the CQ it was personal.
What could be personal between you and me?
Look, Douglas, I, uh...
I really want to help you.
What makes you think I need any?
Don't you get the picture, kid?
If the Army goes ahead with this, you're in serious trouble.
They have to find you guilty. They have to appease Japanese public opinion.
I don't believe that. Believe what you want. I'm giving it to you straight.
You'll be lucky to get off with only a court-martial.
Right now, you're headed for a Japanese trial.
The Army wouldn't do that.
Wait and see.
How do you think your story will stand up against that kid's and their courts?
What's your angle, Bronson? What do you want?
Well, maybe I've cut a few corners in my time.
Some, I admit, were shaved pretty close for the story, but...
that's all part of being a reporter.
Sure, I've wrapped the Army when I thought they had it coming.
But only to prove to the brass that the Army wasn't their own private little club.
You haven't answered my question. What's in it for you?
Okay. I want a story.
But there's something a lot bigger than that involved.
The American eagle used to scream every time an American was in trouble.
Now it buries its head in the sand like an ostrich and pretends it doesn't see.
But it can still hear. And I intend to make it sit up and listen.
Just what do you want me to do?
Don't let him push you around. Let me get a good lawyer to handle your case.
You're going to need outside help.
I'll take my chances with the Army.
They've always given me a fair shake.
Okay, Douglas. Okay.
I can see you now rotting in some stinking Japanese prison.
If you change your mind, you know where you can get in touch with me.
Thanks.
I'll see you later.
Sumi is calling again. You want to talk to her?
No. Tell her I'm still busy.
Hi.
You better pack your gear.
What's up?
I have to deliver you to Camp Zama.
Camp Zama? What for?
I'm not sure, but the scuttlebutt has it you're to be turned over to the Japanese for trial.
I must have been in Japan longer than I thought.
I'm beginning to enjoy this music.
Yeah, it sure has a beat.
Makes you feel like dancing.
I'll see you later.
This is no time to worry about whose fault it is.
I didn't expect Douglas to take off.
You get every available man out looking for him.
Turn the Ginza inside out if you have to, but find him.
Yes, sir.
Tell the men to keep it quiet. Dismissed.
Right, sir.
Pardon me, Major.
What do you want?
There's a Sumi Fujita outside. She wants to see Sergeant Douglas.
Show her in. She may help.
-1
This way, please.
Ms. Fujita, come in.
I'm Major Bradley. I'm Douglas' commanding officer.
What can I do for you?
I would like to speak with Sergeant Douglas.
Why did you speak with him last?
Not for two days.
You didn't talk to him today at all?
No. Is something wrong?
What has happened?
Sit down, won't you, Ms. Fujita?
You know about the death of the boy.
You know how delicate and sensitive this situation has become.
The friendship, the goodwill between Japan and the United States...
may very well depend on how we handle the situation.
That's why I'm going to take a chance in confiding you...
in the hope that you may be able to help us and Sergeant Douglas.
I will do anything to help Robert.
You probably heard on the radio...
we were planning to transfer Douglas to Japanese authority.
About an hour ago, he broke restriction.
He struck a guard and disappeared.
It is all my fault.
Why do you say that?
When all this trouble happened...
he asked for my understanding, but I doubted him.
If I, who was closest to him, did not have faith...
what hope could he have in others?
I imagine he feels the army has let him down, too.
In a way, I can understand that.
He must be made to realize that isn't true.
He'll probably try to contact you.
I'd like you to phone me when that happens.
You ask very much.
Well, his running away is no solution.
It only makes things worse.
He must come back. It's best for him.
You would not hurt him?
I'd give him my word.
I will call you.
Thank you.
Goodbye, Major.
Goodbye.
Miss Fujita...
I think Sergeant Douglas is a lucky man.
Kobawa.
So you remember me, huh?
Now, take it easy, sonny.
I just want to talk to you.
Nobody's going to hurt you.
I just want you to tell the truth about what happened.
There's nothing to be afraid of, but you must tell the truth.
Do you understand?
Yes, sir.
Now, look, I heard you speak English, so let's cut the wakarimasen.
I know you understand.
Now, you've got to tell him it was an accident, that you hit the garden.
You lie! You lie!
You're going to tell the truth, or I'll...
I did not do it! I did not do it!
What's the use?
Robert.
How did you know where to find me?
When I heard you ran away,
I thought you would come here to talk to the boy first.
Why, when you were so sure he was telling the truth?
I'm sorry for what happened.
I believe in you. I do.
Maybe we were both a little too quick.
They're searching all over for you.
You must go back.
What good will that do?
That kid won't change his story.
He's too frightened.
This is not the way.
The police will know what to do.
And if they don't?
Running away will not help.
Where will you go?
I don't know.
Alone, you will not be able to hide for a day in Tokyo.
That's a chance I'll have to take.
Robert, you have to let me help you.
I don't want you to get mixed up in this.
Please, I can take you to my teacher's house.
They will not look for you there.
No one will know.
Your teacher won't want me at his house.
Sensei will do it for me.
Come.
It will give us time to think about what to do.
Sumi, I...
Don't say anything.
Sorry I'm late, gentlemen.
I was with the foreign minister for the past two hours.
Mr. Johnson, this is Major Bradley.
How do you do, Major.
What attitude is the government taking?
They want Douglas.
The local press has been crawling with anti-American propaganda.
The pressure on the government is tremendous.
They won't be able to delay a showdown on the issue in the diet much longer.
Have your men located Douglas?
No, we haven't.
Major Bradley has been in contact with Douglas' girl.
We feel sure he'll try to see her before long.
And when he does, we'll be waiting.
Not very encouraging, General.
At the very most, I figure we can stall for about 48 hours, but not more.
Before we'll have to notify the Japanese authorities that we allowed Douglas to escape.
I beg your pardon, sir. We didn't allow him to escape.
An unfortunate choice of words.
I didn't intend to imply negligence on your part.
However, there are certain extremists who would like to have the Japanese people believe that it wasn't negligence, but even deliberate.
We're doing everything in our power.
Without some kind of positive lead, frankly, I'm doubtful of our chance of locating Douglas, even within 48 hours.
Tokyo is a big city.
A lot of places he could be hiding.
Eventually, of course, he's got to turn up.
Major, we're not dealing in eventualities.
In the language of diplomacy, it's imperative.
Gentlemen, my men and I will stick with this around the clock.
Doctor, are you in?
Good evening, Doctor.
Sumi-chan, come in.
Who is it?
I'd be most happy to speak in English.
Who is our guest?
Sensei, I would like you to meet my friend, Sergeant Robert Douglas.
Forgive me if I cannot prove you the formal duties of a host.
Please, sir. I'm very happy to know you.
The sergeant finds himself in difficulty and needs a place to stay a few days.
If it is not too great a burden, may he stay with you?
My house is a large one.
It will be my pleasure to have Sumi's friend remain as my guest for as long as he wishes.
Thank you. You are most kind.
I must hurry to the Ginza for my last show.
Sensei's playing of the koto is known everywhere in Japan.
Perhaps he will play for you until I return.
You flatter my humble talent.
But I fear the music of the koto is not for Western ears.
No, please. I would like very much to hear you play.
Sensei, goodbye.
I'll come back as soon as I can.
Thank you for your visit.
Come on, come on.
Shut up. No, no.
I'm happy. I won, I won. I'm very happy.
Good evening, Miss Fujita.
Thank you, Major Bradley.
Forgive me for asking you to come here, but I could not leave.
I'm happy to see the Ginza. It's been known to me, but only on paper.
-9
Please sit down. May I have a drink brought to you?
-8
No, thanks.
-7
You heard from him?
-6
I must speak to you first. Certainly.
-5
In your office I said I would tell you if I saw Sergeant Douglas.
-4
I'm ashamed, but I cannot do it.
-3
But then you've seen him. Where is he? Where's he hiding?
-2
Please, Major Bradley, I've tried to think of what is the right thing to do.
-1
Douglas has to give himself up.
Perhaps it is best that he gives himself up to the infuse.
I do not know. Robert must decide for himself.
You would be helping him.
Perhaps an American girl would do it your way.
I must do it my way. I know he will do right.
Suppose it's foolish of me to try to balance my logic against the feeling of your heart.
If you would just let me see him.
You know I want Douglas to turn himself in. I want to help him personally.
And I can. Believe me.
I believe you, but there is nothing I can do.
Let me talk to him just for a few minutes.
I'm sure I can convince him of the right course to take.
If he were to meet you, would you be alone?
I don't have the right to do it, but...
Okay. Just myself.
You will be alone.
There'll be no one else.
Then be at the Koyasan Temple tomorrow night at 9 o'clock.
No one will see us there.
I cannot promise, but I will try to bring Robert.
Thank you, Miss Fujii.
Incidentally, what is this that you've been making?
Atsuru.
For Japanese, it means good luck.
Hello, Major.
Sumi.
Bronson.
Nice to see you in the Ginza.
I heard so much about Sumi's beauty, I had to see for myself.
Thank you.
I must dress now. Please excuse me.
I was told that you visited Douglas in his quarters.
CQ let me in.
What did you talk about?
I don't have to answer your question, Major,
but I will.
We talked about Americans who get in trouble away from home.
Bronson, I hope you understand the difference
between freedom of the press and irresponsibility.
THE END
The garden is so peaceful at night.
I didn't even hear you come in.
We say the troubles of the day disappear in the serenity of the garden.
And we say a man's troubles disappear in the arms of the woman he loves.
I missed you, Sumi.
Robert, there's something I want to talk about.
All right. Am I intruding?
Where did you come from?
The instinct of an old newsman.
I saw Sumi with the Major and I thought I'd tag along.
The Major?
I tried to tell you.
We'll talk about it later.
All right, Bronson. Now that you know, what are you going to do?
You got me all wrong. I'm not going to turn you in.
I still want to help.
Now that everything has happened that I said would happen,
for a change, listen to reason.
Okay, so you were right. But I still don't think you can help me.
I can do more than you think.
Like what, for instance?
When I get through with you, they won't dare turn you over.
That sounds great, but I can't hide out in Japan forever, you know.
That's the best part of it. I'll get you back to the States.
The States? What good would that do?
They'd ship me back here the minute I got there.
When I finish, there'll be 170 million Americans behind you.
We'll start a fire under Congress.
Take it to the Supreme Court if we have to.
Just how would you get me out of Japan?
Leave it to me. I'll get you to Frisco and surrender you there.
They won't dare bring you back for trial.
Are you game?
I'm probably a fool for even listening to you.
I know it'll work.
You just have to give me your word.
I'll have to think it over.
Don't take too long.
I'll let you know tomorrow.
Good. You won't regret it.
Good night, Suli.
I will see you to the gate.
No, thank you. I'll go the way I came.
What were you doing with the Major?
I tried to tell you before.
The Major wants to talk with you.
I'm sure he would.
He and a couple of hundred MPs.
No, Robert, please. He will meet you alone, in secret.
What for?
He said he wants to help you.
It's too late for him to do anything for me now.
He has to look out for his own neck.
If you at least talk with the Major, maybe you won't have to run away.
I tell you, it won't do any good.
Please try it.
For me.
All right.
All right, I'll try.
Douglas?
Is that you?
Douglas, are you here?
It's Sumi, Major.
I'm alone. Nobody else is here.
Here I am, Major.
Hello, Sergeant.
Sumi said you wanted to talk.
Yes.
I was wondering if I could get you to see the whole picture.
I'm not interested in the whole picture.
I'm looking out for myself.
The day you signed up for the army, you gave up the luxury of looking out for yourself.
That's right, Major, but I enlisted in the American army, not the Japanese.
Still, the American army is giving you orders.
And will it be an American or a Japanese prison?
Frankly, I doubt it'll be either.
I find the Japanese are just as fair as any American court, but that's beside the point, Sergeant.
You don't have a choice.
You've been ordered to stand trial.
And for the first time, I'm going to disobey an order.
We'll catch you.
You know that.
Then you'll stand a court-martial as well as a Japanese trial.
You can't get away with it.
Maybe not, but I'm going to try.
Let me speak to you honestly.
As an army officer, sure, I'd like to see your surrender.
I'd like to see this whole affair ended with no more publicity.
And just as honestly, I'd like to get you out of this mess.
The least possible injury to you.
But that means you've got to face the issue squarely and directly.
You can't run from it.
I don't see it that way.
I've got other plans.
Sergeant, I want you to come back with me now.
That's an order.
I came here on your word, Major.
Don't force me to do something we'll both regret.
If you don't turn yourself in, there's not a thing I can do for you.
I'll take my chances.
You don't leave me much choice.
I'll give you 24 hours more.
24 hours more.
Tomorrow night, I'm informing the Japanese authorities...
that they'll use any means necessary to bring you in.
Dead or alive.
Sumi will stay with you until I'm away from the temple.
Goodbye, Major.
Now, I said we'd do it.
Headlines all over the country.
Congress screaming for an investigation.
The American Legion demanding your release.
We're in.
It's bigger than I thought.
There was a mass protest meeting in Springfield.
Even your mother was on TV.
Did you have to bring her into this?
Relax. Nobody's getting hurt.
Let me handle this.
You have every mother in America praying for you.
All right, all right. Handle it your own way.
When do Sumi and I leave?
Sumi can't go. I thought you understood.
What do you mean? If she doesn't go, I don't.
Wait a minute. Be reasonable. There's such a thing as a passport.
Then get her one.
We haven't got time.
Trying to get a passport for Sumi now would be a dead giveaway.
Okay, Bronson. The deal is off.
Look, if you leave as arranged,
after we spring the surprise, I'll have Sumi sent over.
It won't be more than a few weeks.
Why, you could even be married over there.
Better yet, I'll arrange a wedding in San Francisco.
I don't know.
How does that sound to you?
Whatever you think is best.
You better not let me down, Bronson.
Don't worry, kid. I won't.
Okay, when do I leave?
You ship out on a freighter tomorrow night.
I'm getting Seaman's papers.
I'll pick you up in town around 10 o'clock.
We'll drive down to Yokohama together.
When will we meet him?
I cannot be with you.
I must stay at the Ginza.
If I'm not there, they may suspect.
I'll meet you at the Ginza.
Robert, it is dangerous.
The MPs have been watching the Ginza.
She's right. The Ginza may be too hard for you.
No, no, it's the last place they'd look for me.
I'll sneak into Sumi's dressing room through a door in the rear.
Nobody will see me there.
You know the MPs better than I do.
Well, I'd better get going.
I'll see you to the door.
Sumi, take care of him.
He's valuable property.
I'll see you tomorrow, kid.
It won't be for long.
Hey, hey, what's this?
Come on, get up.
I'm trying to be brave.
But I'm so afraid you'll go to America and we'll never see each other again.
Oh, darling, that's not true.
We'll be together in two weeks.
I love you so much.
I don't want to live without you.
I love you.
Good morning.
I made you coffee, American style.
Thank you.
You do not like how I make coffee?
Oh, no, no, it's fine, honestly.
No.
I'll be the luckiest man in the whole United States.
Will they like me in Springfield, Illinois?
They won't like you. They'll love you.
Is it cold there?
Well, I guess it's about the same as it is here.
Maybe a little hotter than summertime.
No cherry blossoms.
Will we have a house of our own?
You bet we will.
Two bedrooms and a den.
Bath and three quarters.
And no doubt, David, you'll love it.
I will love what you love.
Robert, if we cannot be together,
I will not be sorry.
I'm grateful for the happiness we shared.
Suzie, don't talk like that.
Everything is going to work out.
I heard many soldiers were ashamed to their Japanese brides in America.
So be it.
Robert, please, promise to tell me when you no longer love me.
I'll always love you.
Forgive me, sensei. I did not wish to disturb you.
The sergeant has listened to more than enough koto for one day.
I've enjoyed your playing very much.
You are too kind.
You have been most generous. Thank you for your kindness.
Goodbye.
It has been my pleasure.
See you at the Ginza.
I'll be happy to help.
I'll see you again later at the Ginza.
Please be careful.
Thank you.
Will you join me in a cup of tea?
Thank you, Sensei.
Our tea is perhaps a little too bitter for your American taste.
No, I've become accustomed to it.
To us, it is a symbol of the bitterness of life in our poor country.
-6
than the taste.
-5
It is part of the Japanese character to try and see beauty in that which might be considered
-4
ugly and unpleasant.
-3
I've seen a tea ceremony performed many times, but frankly I never knew what it was all about.
-2
You are honest.
-1
Most Westerners wish so anxiously to see the beauty of Japanese customs that they believe
they do.
But it is more than seeing.
Our ceremonies, our music, our kabuki, are the products of our own culture.
One has to be Japanese to understand and appreciate their beauty.
Do you really believe that we're so different?
Of course we are different.
Even you understand that.
What do you mean?
Your present troubles.
You know about that.
A blind man learns to see without his eyes.
I don't think my present troubles have anything to do with understanding the Japanese.
Forgive me, Sergeant.
I do not wish to offend you.
I've traveled all over Japan, been here for three years, spoken to all kinds of people.
Spoken?
And how many of those people were able to express themselves in modern pidgin English?
The barrier of language prevented them from saying one-tenth of what they were thinking.
And so, like with many Americans, a true understanding never developed.
Sumi and I have learned to understand each other.
You have learned how to love each other.
But have you learned to understand?
I don't follow.
Have you considered what Sumi is giving up to go with you to America?
Her parents, her friends, her career, her whole way of life?
We've talked about it.
She's willing.
You have no doubt, told her, that the color of her skin will make no difference in America?
It won't.
You expect Sumi to accept your customs, your laws, and submit to your justice, and yet...
That's not a just comparison.
Isn't it?
No.
Then why are you running?
Because I'm not getting a fair deal.
Be honest with yourself.
That is not the reason.
You are running away because it is not an American, but a Japanese who will pass judgment
on you.
And what would you have me do, give myself up?
Is that the only answer?
Well, I don't see it.
Riding in some prison won't do Sumi or me any good.
I am afraid I am spoiling your last memories of Japan.
Forgive an old fool.
You took a long enough time getting here.
The streets are crawling with M.P.'s.
I had to be careful.
You're the one who wanted to meet here.
Any other place would have been better.
Stop beefing, will you, Bronson?
Where's Sumi?
We haven't got time for Sumi.
I have to get you to that pier by 11 o'clock.
Here are your sealant papers.
Your name is George Kowalski.
Now let's get going.
We'll wait for Sumi.
Don't be a fool, Bob.
I said we'll wait, Bronson.
We haven't got all night.
I'll be right back.
But...
Robert, the M.P.'s will see you.
No, they won't.
I'll be gone in just a second.
I'm so afraid.
Let's get moving.
Sumi, I...
I know.
Now, Bronson will make all the arrangements for you.
I love you.
Please go, Robert.
You don't want to...
You don't remember me like this.
Sumi, you're talking like you're not going to come to me.
You will, won't you?
Please, Robert.
Everything is so confused.
You want me to stay and face it, don't you?
Don't you?
I cannot tell you what to do.
You must decide for both of us.
There's no more time for talk.
Shut up, will you?
If we don't leave now, our whole plan goes up in smoke.
You can't change your mind.
I just did.
Okay.
Okay, soldier.
It'll make a good story either way.
You got me.
I'll go back to the station.
You know what was right all along, didn't you?
No, Robert.
You did.
You won't be afraid.